In this segment, we start
a discussion of multiple
continuous random variables.
Here are some objects that we're
already familiar with.
But exactly as in the discrete
case, if we are dealing with
two random variables, it is
not enough to know their
individual PDFs.
We also need to model the
relation between the two
random variables, and this is
done through a joint PDF,
which is the continuous analog
of the joint PMF.
We will use this notation to
indicate joint PDFs where we
use f to indicate that we're
dealing with a density.
So what remains to be done is to
actually define this object
and see how we use it.
Let us start by recalling that
joint PMFs were defined in
terms of the probability that
the pair of random variables X
and Y take certain specific
values little x and little y.
Regarding joint PDFs, we start
by saying that it has to be
non-negative.
However, a more precise
interpretation in terms of
probabilities has to
wait a little bit.
Joint PDFs will be used to
calculate probabilities.
And this will be done
in analogy with
the discrete setting.
In the discrete setting, the
probability that the pair of
random variables falls inside a
certain set is just the sum
of the probabilities of all of
the possible pairs inside that
particular set.
For the continuous case,
we introduce
an analogous formula.
We use the joint density instead
of the joint PMF.
And instead of having a
summation, we now integrate.
As in the discrete setting,
we have one total unit of
probability.
The joint PDF tells us how this
unit of probability is
spread over the entire
continuous
two-dimensional plane.
And we use it, we use the joint
PDF, to calculate the
probability of a certain set
by finding the volume under
the joint PDF that lies
on top of that set.
This is what this integral
really represents.
We integrate over a particular
two-dimensional set, and we
take this value that
we integrate.
And we can think of this as the
height of an object that's
sitting on top of that set.
Now, this relation here, this
calculation of probabilities,
is not something that we
are supposed to prove.
This is, rather, the
definition of
what a joint PDF does.
A legitimate joint PDF is any
function of two variables,
which is non-negative and
which integrates to 1.
And we will say that two random
variables are jointly
continuous if there is a
legitimate joint PDF that can
be used to calculate the
associated probabilities
through this particular
formula.
So we have really an indirect
definition.
Instead of defining the joint
PDF as a probability, we
actually define it indirectly by
saying what it does, how it
will be used to calculate
probabilities.
A picture will be
helpful here.
Here's a plot of a possible
joint PDF.
These are the x and y-axes.
And the function being plotted
is the joint PDF of these two
random variables.
This joint PDF is higher at
some places and lower at
others, indicating that certain
regions of the x,y
plane are more likely
than others.
The joint PDF determines the
probability of a set B by
integrating over that set B.
Let's say it's this set.
Integrating the PDF
over that set.
Pictorially, what this means is
that we look at the volume
that sits on top of that set,
but below the PDF, below the
joint PDF, and so we obtain some
three-dimensional object
of this kind.
And this integral corresponds
to actually finding this
volume here, the volume that
sits on top of the set B but
which is below the joint PDF.
Let us now develop some
additional understanding of
joint PDFs.
As we just discussed, for any
given set B, we can integrate
the joint PDF over that set.
And this will give us
the probability of
that particular set.
Of particular interest is the
case where we're dealing with
a set which is a rectangle, in
which case the situation is a
little simpler.
So suppose that we have
a rectangle where the
x-coordinate ranges from A to B
and the y-coordinate ranges
from some C to some D. Then, the
double integral over this
particular rectangle can be
written in a form where we
first integrate with respect to
one of the variables that
ranges from A to B. And then, we
integrate over all possible
values of y as they
range from C to D.
Of particular interest is the
special case where we're
dealing with a small rectangle
such as this one.
A rectangle with sizes equal to
some delta where delta is a
small number.
In that case, the double
integral, which is the volume
on top of that rectangle,
is simpler to evaluate.
It is equal to the value of
the function that we're
integrating at some point in the
rectangle --- let's take
that corner ---
times the area of that little
rectangle, which is equal to
delta square.
So we have an interpretation of
the joint PDF in terms of
probabilities of small
rectangles.
Joint PDFs are not
probabilities.
But rather, they are probability
densities.
They tell us the probability
per unit area.
And one more important
comment.
For the case of a single
continuous random variable, we
know that any single point
has 0 probability.
This is again, true for the case
of two jointly continuous
random variables.
But more is true.
If you take a set B
that has 0 area.
For example, a certain curve.
Suppose that this curve is the
entire set B. Then, the volume
under the joint PDF that's
sitting on top of that curve
is going to be equal to 0.
So 0 area sets have
0 probability.
And this is one of the
characteristic features of
jointly continuous
random variables.
Now, let's think of a particular
situation.
Suppose that X is a continuous
random variable, and let Y be
another random variable, which
is identically equal to X.
Since X is a continuous random
variable, Y is also a
continuous random variable.
However, in this situation, we
are certain that the outcome
of the experiment is going
to fall on the line
where x equals y.
All the probability lies
on top of a line, and
a line has 0 area.
So we have positive probability
on the set of 0
area, which contradicts what
we discussed before.
Well, this simply means that
X and Y are not jointly
continuous.
Each one of them is continuous,
but together
they're not jointly
continuous.
Essentially, joint continuity
is something more than
requiring each random variable
to be continuous by itself.
For joint continuity, we want
the probability to be really
spread over two dimensions.
Probability is not allowed
to be concentrated on a
one-dimensional set.
On the other hand, in this
example, the probability is
concentrated on a
one-dimensional set.
And we do not have
joint continuity.